so the next story is um you know
as women we make super wise decisions
and you know as we've studied women get
divorced for real reasons you know we
are just super abused and have it so
hard and you know when we get divorced
it's for super valid reasons so I regret
so today we have a submission from a
girl talking about her divorce and
actually regretting it she says I regret
not making my marriage work and now my
ex-husband is happily remarried when I
was in my early 30s I divorced my
husband we didn't have any major issues
our relationship was just challenged
after having kids I was a stay-at-home
mom and I expected him to do more of the
housework and the child care when he
worked full-time he did not help me when
I asked but I started to ask more of him
and I burnt him out I used to have him
wrapped around my finger and I used that
as an advantage to get what I want he
eventually got tired of it I started
threatening to divorce him and he said
he knew the baby was just stressing us
out and he will he would like to make it
work but when I was 30 I thought I was a
great catch because I was still very
beautiful for my age and I lost my mom
bod so I thought I could do better than
him so I left him I got
I got our house in the divorce and we
shared joint custody of our son fast
forward now I'm 41 and still single and
my ex-husband is 41 and got remarried to
a 31 year old woman who is incredibly
beautiful they had their daughter three
years ago he bought a new house and my
son loves going to his dad's house to
spend time with his other family and I'm
not gonna lie it makes me jealous she
has it all she took my husband she took
my kid she took my life that was once
all mine and all I have is the house we
created our family in and now I live in
an empty house I'm 41 I gained 20 pounds
I've got wrinkles and I'm alone and
miserable I've had short-term
relationships after the divorce but they
never worked out men just don't want an
old woman like me with a child and I've
noticed that men with kids just have a
better time dating with kids than we do
and I hate it
so there you have it ladies you know and
that's why a lot of people think that
red pill is harsh but the truth of the
matter is that the red pill is honest
and I think a lot of single mothers
leave relationships thinking that
there's better on the other side I think
a lot of single mothers leave the father
of their children for selfish reasons
and you know the media tries to pretend
that women have valid reasons for
divorce when really the truth of the
matter is guys that there's only a
couple you know semi-valid reasons for
divorce abuse adultery addiction I'll
give you guys those
but outside of that like we forget what
the actual vows are first richer or for
poorer in sickness and in health till
death to us part not until we get bored
or thinking that we can do better you
know I I think in America and especially
amongst women we've really lost feeling
content
you know I think social media has
convinced us that there's always a
better option that there is always
something good around the corner and it
really makes us women live in la la land
and you know I really do appreciate the
men that have made content that is
honest to women because what you start
to realize when you get more and more
red pill is guys see see this craziness
you know men typically don't live in la
la land because you know men
more so than women I'll say see what's
true so when we're divorcing for stupid
reasons or like leaving for stupid
reasons the men can see it stupid but
they don't they like guys just they
don't want the drama so a lot of guys
aren't going to tell you
um and that's why I really appreciate
the content that
fresh and fit and a lot of the other red
pill guys have made